first the furlough scheme
will be extended until the end of
september
for employees there will be no change to
the terms
they will continue to receive 80 of
their salary
for hours not worked until the scheme
ends
as businesses reopen we will ask them to
contribute alongside the taxpayer
to the cost of paying their employees
nothing will change
until july when we will ask for a small
contribution
of just 10 and 20 in august
and september the government is proud
of the furlough one of the most generous
schemes in the world
effectively protecting millions of
people's jobs
and incomes second
support for the self-employed will also
continue
until september with a fourth grant
covering the period february to april
and a fifth and final grant from may
onwards
the fourth grant will provide three
months of support at
80 percent of average trading profits
for the fifth grant
people will continue to receive grants
worth three months of
average profits with the system open for
claims
from late july but as the economy
reopens over the summer
it is fair to target our support
towards those most affected by the
pandemic
so people whose turnover has fallen by
30
or more will continue to receive the
full
80 percent grant people whose turnover
has fallen by less than 30 percent will
therefore have less need
of taxpayer support and will receive
a 30 grand and i can also announce a
major improvement in
access to the self-employed scheme
when the scheme was launched the newly
self-employed couldn't qualify
because they hadn't all filed the 1920
tax return
but as the tax return deadline has now
passed
i can announce today that provided they
filed a tax return by midnight last
night
over 600 000 more people
many of whom became self-employed last
year can now claim the fourth
and fifth grants
over the course of this crisis we will
have spent
33 billion pounds supporting the
self-employed
one of the most generous programs for
self-employed people
anywhere in the world third
we're also extending our support for the
lowest paid
and most vulnerable to support
low-income households
the universal credit uplift of 20 pounds
a week
will continue for a further six months
well beyond the end of this national
lockdown
we'll provide working tax credit
claimants with equivalent support
for the next six months and because of
the way that system works operationally
we will need to do so with a one-off
payment of 500 pounds
and over the course of this year as the
economy begins to recover
we are shifting our resources and focus
towards getting people into decent
well-paid jobs
we reaffirm our commitment to end low
pay
increasing the national living wage to
eight pounds 91
from april an annual pay rise of almost
350 pounds
for someone working full time on the
national living wage
and my right honourable friends the
education secretary
and the work and pension secretary are
taking action
to give people the skills they need to
get jobs
or get better jobs the restart program
supporting over a million long-term
unemployed people
the number of work coaches doubled the
kickstart scheme
funding high quality jobs for over a
quarter of a million young people
the prime minister's lifetime skills
guarantee giving
every adult the opportunity for a fully
funded level three qualification
and we want businesses to hire new
apprentices
so we're paying them more to do it today
i am doubling the incentive payments we
give businesses
to 3 000 pounds that's for all
new apprentice hires of any age
alongside investing 126 million pounds
of
new money to triple the number of
traineeships
we're taking what works to get people
into jobs and making it
better